bonsoir
et de message pour dire faut éteindre
c'est la lumière qui attire les rappeurs
alors pétitionnent vous arrivez du
zénith le concert s'est bien passé
super c'était génial est-ce que tu as
croisé lollobrigida dans les collèges a
croisé une dame âgée avec des bijoux
c'est servir
comment comment trouvez-vous le public
français fifty cent
il était super il est évident grand une
belle présence tout le monde était là
pour écouter c'est génial et vous aime
les gens ici
alors
béatrice dalle bruno béatrice dalle non
non je suis désolé je ne sais quoi n'y
aa
non désolé
et
lui c'est mc jean gab 1 mc jean gab'1
kaki et 1,3 milliard voilà et m6 baverel
m6 bat breizh
izel lez y arriver
si la presse que ce qui paye mon cher
pays qui sert cocaïne
alors vous savez quand même que fifty
sonne c'est le premier rappeur qui a été
signé sur le label de eminem et dr dre
qui s'appelle chats dits oui cordes et
quand vous avez signé le contrat de dr
dre vous a dit es-tu prêt à rentrer dans
l'histoire quand même c'est vrai que
c'est un événement puisque ils vous ont
choisi
ils m'ont choisi c'était c'était un
événement
ils m'ont dit que l'avenir lettres
nouveau oui ça s'est passé d'ailleurs
alors ils ont offert un million de
dollars pour le contrat vous aviez des
offres à 1 millions 26 vous avez quand
même choisi eminem et dr dre 1
parce que sur le plan créatif je pouvais
pas obtenir la même chose pas qu'une
question d'argent oui alors vous avez eu
raison de signer avec eux parce que ça a
boosté votre votre cd et vous en avez
vendu six millions aux usa voilà ça vous
plaît nicolas le hip hop le cinquième
budget total
non mais les parkings étaient fabuleux
c'est qu'il ya eu un délit mélodique
extraordinaire oui là il ya 110 avec lui
donc c'est vachement bien bravo ça vous
plaise ou non ah si aulas vous êtes très
chanceux parce qu'ils aiment personne
n'y en a pas vous êtes le premier qu'il
aime ce soir on a eu du pot
coup de bol alors on vous appelle
filtisac mais votre vrai nom c'est
qu'artiste jackson vous avez une enfance
difficile dans le queens et dans
l'endroit le plus violent du queens à
new york qui s'appelle saf jamaïca vous
avez élevé là votre mère sabrina est
décédé à l'âge de 23 ans à l'époque vous
aviez huit ans elle vous avez eu à l'âge
de 15 ans
votre mère vendait du crack
est ce que vous mettez à faire
d'ailleurs vous aussi dès l'âge de 12
ans et c'est vrai vous dites en restant
huit ans de plus au bahut j'allais tout
juste pour voir décrocher un job qui me
permettent d'acheter une caisse
d'occasion vous dit le deal n'était pas
une solution c'était la seule solution
c'est grave ça grands maintenant ce
qui se passe et que dans certains cas
quand on grandit dans un quartier comme
ça quand on n'a pas d'argent l'argent
semble à peu près impossible
c'est la solution à tous les problèmes
ont trouvé un moyen de trouver sa maman
elle a fait ce qu'il fallait pour plus
nourrir
alors après la prison quand vous devenez
papa d'un petit garçon vous prenez un
peu vos distances avec le deal et le
milieu du crime et vous rentrez dans le
rap et vous rencontrez vous avez
beaucoup de chance vous rencontrez jam
master jay de run dmc ce qu'on fait la
chanson avec aerosmith et vous faites un
premier album qui s'appelle power of
dollars
mais à ce moment là je comprends pas
pourquoi vous vous commencez vous
toucher 250 mille dollars pour faire cet
album et pourtant vous continuez à dix
les du crack comment
j'avais effectivement 250 mille dollars
sur le contrat ouais mais l'avant ce
n'était que de 65 mille dollars
5000 de la circulation à
la sortie publique de la ensuite
certaine somme pour l'avocat pour les
juristes enfin
ses 5000 $ en poche
j'avais de quoi vivre pendant un an et
demi à dire ça serait parfait et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il a fallu d'autres
solutions d'accord alors on mai 2000 le
24 mai exactement vous promener dans le
quartier du queen's en jeep quand un
inconnu vous tire dessus avec un 9 mm et
vous prenez 9 balles dans le corps vous
arrivez malgré tout à conduire jusqu'à
l'hôpital jamaïca vous savez qui vous
attire et ses neuf balles dans le corps
je n'ai pas personnellement
et que cela étant ça vient de ma vie
avant la musique ouais vous avez peur
aujourd'hui encore nous faire tirer
dessus non non ça qu'il prend 9 balles
et quittant sorte on a rien à jeter
quand même alors voilà donc à ce moment
là la maison de disques columbia refuse
de vous gardez vous retournez dans
l'underground à vos racines et vous
rencontrer à ce moment là voilà le
manager de eminem est là tout va bien
c'est un conte de fées qui commence
puisque comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure
vous en vendez 6 millions 4 mois mais
vous avez toujours quand même un petit
peu d'aidé
c'est toujours un peu des embrouilles
avec la police n'ont quand même malgré
tout nord malgré tout
deux pas de grosses embrouilles disent
oh oui dernièrement vous avez eu un
problème de port d'armes vous avez un
petit problème de port d'armes vous a
été pris dans une fusillade
et vous savez quand même que quand vous
allez revenir aux états unis vous devez
allez vous présenter à la police quand
même fifty sainte vous savez ça
la police est toujours très bon bt avec
des trucs
pour un flingue alors aujourd'hui tout
va bien vous acheter un château il
achète un château pour mettre le crack
il achète un château à deux heures de
new york qui est un très beau château
qui était la demeure de mike tyson s'est
vous êtes en train de racheter pour
quand même quatre millions d'euros c'est
pas mal 4 millions d'euros ça fait
combien à toi qui sais compter
26 millions oui c'est bien dit dont
elle est belle la maison à ce prix là
non
comment as tu en as les commandes la
maison sérieuse
soixantaine de chambres vous pourrez à
accueillir des amis
des gens construire un tiers vers une
belle idée une idée alors on écrit un
film sur vous aussi le scénariste des
soprano est en train d'écrire un film
sur vous
absolument oui c'est vrai you started
sur un site
sera bientôt tourné c'est la réussite
avec un guide et
le succès dont mm avec le film de et
marc ça m'a beaucoup aidé et puis ça
fait quand même un lancement
et ben non ils m'aiment bien aussi ouais
vous connaissez le rap français
mais quand une fille française ne parle
d'une vidéo
béatrice
est ce que ça veut dire samia traduit
nous aussi
d'ailleurs du baston là au [ __ ] c'est
joey starr
le mari de béatrice est très très
méchant il a failli me tuer une fois
qu'il n'y ait pas eu
photo mike tyson a conduit tombe bien
aussi oui j'oubliais dire que je m'étais
mal connu et c'est vrai mais depuis on
serait conciliant ça va très bien merci
ça que mes matches youtube est
libre ils couchent et mieux vous vous
avez pas vous promener dans la ville et
tout ça non mais c'est un joueur on va
rentrer sagement la maison merci d'avoir
aidé les jeunes
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux